ha ha here we go again versus Yardbird
and now not five yep the opening
challenge is in effect can I score
against Yardbird I lost all the recent
games I don't know not been in not
playing well against him I remember one
or two occasions where I support fairly
fairly easy wins so something like this
is possible i believe castling f6 this
kind of business here come on x and f 6
49 f seven and then Bishop d7 try to in
the long run do something with them with
the two bishops but I don't know how it
is played probably not on the queenside
and now that I think of it but ok I
might have a 5 here right I have Bishop
f5 ok yeah still plays it ok
yah that move oh all right should think
first at least a little bit especially
if the opponent is not exactly a bad
player wow wow there that's a disaster
that's really a disaster this position
96 was already resigned after that what
am I doing here that's a bad game when
my playing nonsense against him in the
last couple of games this is weird I'm i
am playing that opening a bit too
quickly then that's its belly one reason
it's not familiar ground and I'm trying
to be quick and not getting to you to
time pressure and being quick is okay in
my own openings but maybe here it's not
such a great idea okay
don't don't really know him a position
is so bad you can play all kinds of
stuff may be here for gift to what might
still be mildly interesting if i can get
this when i hit some easier ways to to
win so much I'm not threatening Rugare
to at the moment ready look 8f 293 just
wins yeah man maybe maybe it's not
winning so easily if I take them look a
deaf too let's think about this can
check I can give a couple of checks them
93 luckily to king of one rogue age too
maybe this is really working threaten
the meat down and if he goes on the
second-ranked I can take that take on
these three ma'am don't really I don't
think i have a mat have a choice their
primary check that was my idea look h1
made and the night is still hanging so
he doesn't have a simple night move or
something that that's not working and
while i can check me of course a couple
of times maybe some kind of checking
sequences the key
maybe but maybe I'm just winning the
piece back check check at least I have
no choice him and now he's returning it
so let's think for one moment at just
one moment here and here so now i think
a four is there a threat their rookie
701 I don't get it maybe just this this
is simple so wow I'm back in this game
cannot really believe it but it seems
like it I might I might be a little bit
better here even I am not really but see
5 or a for what makes lots of sense
yeah maybe maybe c-5m looks it too
hectic g-form see for King III it's just
about holding maybe this one h5 and then
I'm going around with the king I go
there check Kinney 6 and now he's doing
that hmm okay yeah likely would have a
draw is very high
Jeff
Jack look aged six for example assam is
a fairly easy drawn Jeff Jeff can I have
some how do something here okie dokie
six check in d5 rook age six just it
wrong Jeff I can try check
yeah a useless thing is come on girl
offered draw offer this drawing thing is
it's it's useless even if i win the age
phone it's just of course a total draw
it's completely pointless yeah I mean
you can just jettison the porn it's very
something that is useful for you to know
if chat something okay it doesn't need
to defend it like here somewhere not
blundering stuff here I'm taking this
and he just goes down puts the rook here
and now we can just stay on the first
rank this is something that is a special
thing with the night phones yeah with
the night pants white can just stay in
front of the pond and can can shuffle
around and I have no way forward it's a
draw in many ways yeah there's also
fully doors defend on the third-ranked
and so on but this is the absolute
easiest way to keep the draw and can be
easily done even if you have absolutely
no time on the clock so it is a useful
thing to remember with the Jeep on yeah
this is of course a game that I should
have lost quite quite quickly yeah so
this is really kind of ridiculous hear
what I did probably queen bee six
already is kind of kind of wacky but
went here five now yeah this is just
this is terrible it's just terrible this
position c8 I mean probably after maybe
something like that I'm covering this
this was one problem you know there's
always after this be five different do
this my bishop eggs and my whole
position is crumbling them so here here
take stakes and I am just like yeah just
it's just terribly bad it's just
terribly bad okay you just had this
let's say I'm going somewhere and yeah I
mean this is not even necessary
I've rope the eight ok I have roped you
ate so maybe this is why I didn't go in
ipv6 I I see the point but had stitches
terrible this position here look at it
okay that was like this good thinking
and after rookie seven rook ff2 it's
really a draw cool so I saw that that
correctly it really is a drawing i
mighta had some some chance there
because I don't think it's a
particularly great idea to play edge
from this is giving me more
opportunities but it's it's probably it
still a draw em my king is also my king
is not not good there on age six and
whenever I go around you can that's a
draw it's just a draw so very lucky
after this after this opening okay here
what yeah a four is tougher thats it's
probably true where it's still drawn
okay well thanks for watching